I have no idea what that happens it's
not any kind of the system uh it just
feels right and there are certain times
when I'm in the middle of an outline and
I'm i'm building the novel and I'm uh
thinking about okay where it's gonna go
and then feeling my way through where it
should go or trying to track the journey
of the narrator and where he's going to
end up and along the way they'll be
characters where I think oh this guy
needs to come in well who is this guy Oh
for example in lunar park the Bret
Easton Ellis character lives on Elsinore
lane in this big mansion and I wanted to
give him neighbors you know I wanted
something to live by him and I thought
about this you know minor character from
the rules of attraction called I think
Mitchell Allen and I thought oh that
would be really funny because Brett in
the novel went to college with Mitchell
who was a character in the rule of
attraction and that'll be fun to riff on
you know a paragraph or two about their
college days together and I don't know
that's just how it happens but you know
I'm asked this question a lot there is
no plan it just feels right and it's
just something that I like to do
well for me and made the book um a lot
more exciting to write because I was
kind of stuck in that book I was
scratching my head a lot while I was
outlining it and it really wasn't coming
together in the way that I wanted to
come together be it was very much about
a fiction writer like myself but I named
in someone else and I'd you know I
raised some autobiographical uh
information and the book this wasn't
coming together for me and I was like
pacing around scratching my head
wondering why and then you know I have
this voice in my head it's the writer I
call him and he said why did you just
make it Bret Easton Ellis why do you
just try that and see what happens and
pretty much the novel was laid out the
way it has been published it was pretty
much laid out that way but the minute
that I put myself in it everything
started to change in terms of the tone
the writing style became much more
personal and I I became completely
committed and more gripped by this novel
that I previously was because um look I
was writing a very autobiographical
novel forget the Stephen King
shenanigans that are in like in the last
third of the book but overall I was
really writing about my dad and my
feelings about my father how difficult
our relationship was one why now you
know everyone has their their daddy
issues and the daddy stories but mine
were weighing heavily on me at this time
and I needed to you know get rid of them
and writing a book for me is often an
exorcism and so with luna park I needed
to go to that place where it was
actually Bret Easton Ellis and not Gail
Fisher or whatever the name of the
character was at the time and because of
that the book became came alive to me
and it started breathing and seemed much
more compelling and then by the time I
finished the book you know a lot of
things had lifted off me it was I think
it was important to go there an
important to do that at least for me